fidèle au poste sébastien beauvais à
québec et madeleine blais morin à ottawa
bonsoir à vous merci d'être là au terme
d'une autre semaine assez chargé et qui
se termine sur une note un peu
dramatique entre eux dans la capitale
nationale de chaudière appalaches
on l'a bien entendu aujourd'hui à quel
point le ton était grave le message
envoyé la population assez clair et les
craintes à ces vivres on va écouter dans
un premier temps donc deux extraits de
cette conférence de presse et on se
parlera ensuite de la difficulté pour
les politiciens dans ce genre de
contexte de faire passer leur message
l'heure est grave dans la capitale
nationale et de chaudière appalaches
on doit chacun chacune aujourd'hui
prendre conscience de la responsabilité
qu'on donne dans cette situation-là qui
on doit faire un choix aujourd'hui dans
nos comportements
soit on suit plus ou moins les règles
qui on continue de laisser ça à l'est
puis on s'expose comme je lé à des
ruptures de soins quand c'est rendu un
moment donné que tu peux plus de faire
opérer ou tu peux plus te faire soigner
pour un autre problème de santé que rien
à voir avec l'aco vide c'est grave
on est un point de bascule et être un
point de bascule c'est dangereux parce
qu'une chance sur deux que l'aiguillé
temps du mauvais côté on est très
conscient que ce qu'on demande à la
population si difficile c'est du sud
mais on n'a pas le choix mais ça a été
ça assez longtemps des l'utilisation de
termes assez fort il faut redoubler
d'efforts il faut se ressaisir c'est un
wake up call sébastien parlant justement
du de la forme de ce message et la
portée que ça peut avoir
madame guilbaud marche sur un fil c'est
à dire que l'objectif est indéniable il
faut éviter des ruptures de service dans
le réseau de la santé il faut que les
gens qui ont besoin de chirurgie
obtiennent ces chirurgies faut que les
gens qui ont besoin de traitement
obtiennent ces traitements la façon d'y
arriver c'est d'éviter le plus possible
que la maladie se propage mais c'est le
pour éviter que la maladie se propage où
le gouvernement marche sur un fil
il veut pas
laisser l'impression que c'est la faute
à la population c'est à dire que madame
guilbaud lance un appel à la
responsabilisation il faut qu'on se
réveille il faut que chacun prenne acte
du fait qu'il faut baisser ses six
contacts sociaux mais en même temps
c'est dangereux pour elles de reporter
la faute sur la population parce que le
gouvernement une part de responsabilité
aussi dans les mesures qu'ils appliquent
pour contenir maladie alors c'est
délicat pour le gouvernement de faire
d'essayer de faire passer ce genre de
message là d'autant qu'il ya une espèce
de saturation dans le message
actuellement des gens sont un peu de
thann et les mesures des contraintes
sanitaires et il voit l'avenir il voit
noël souvenir où on n'aura pas de party
de famille puis voile l'hiver on va s'en
cabanes et à l'intérieur sans pouvoir
aller par exemple avant une soupape au
restaurant tout cas pas dans les dna
dans les prochains jours
donc c'est difficile de faire passer le
message dans le contexte actuel ça c'est
vrai qu'on voit un peu partout au pays à
des degrés divers un madeleine parce que
c'est exactement ça encore une fois le
choix des mots est très très important
oui et il faut frapper l'imaginaire et
justin trudeau a choisi aujourd'hui de
dire pierre
on a eu au canada le plus haut taux le
plus grand nombre de cas depuis le tout
début de la pandémie donc 2007 188 cas
hier donc justin trudeau a tenu à le
dire en même temps le gouvernement
fédéral est peut-être pas aussi coincé
que le lait les gouvernements
provinciaux en ce moment parce qu'elle
pourra faire la microgestion de est ce
que les restaurants vont fermer à quel
moment ils vont rouvrir l et les
gymnases et les salles de spectacle on
est plutôt dans la préparation générale
essayer d'avoir les tests attend un ca
vous essayez d'avoir l'équipement
médical à temps pour pouvoir le
distribuer aux provinces et justin
trudeau avait des bonnes nouvelles en ce
sens là aujourd'hui a annoncé en disant
qu'il avait conclu une entente avec une
autre compagnie mais canadienne cette
fois pour l'approvisionnement en vaccins
donc on est dans des dynamiques
différentes mais de part et d'autre la
façon de passer le message et 6 2 contre
et cette lassitude concernant la
population
on l'attendait des deux côtés des deux
côtés du gouvernement
une lassitude est une forme de répit
lyon faisait aujourd'hui il est juste la
bombe y en a qui qui qui m'ont traité
une certaine colère face à tous à
certains qui doutent carrément de l'amdh
si on veut de l'urgence d'un situation
il là ça devient encore plus difficile
de sébastien oui parce que quand on
doute de l'urgence de la situation quand
on se dit je suis jeune qui jettera
prépare le manège
j'ai très près par la maladie aussi je
ne trancherai pas si malade que ça le
gouvernement doit nous convaincre que
c'est dangereux actuellement vie m'a
fait son message il le répète depuis des
semaines c'est mylène droit je pense la
directrice de santé publique de montréal
qui dit à un moment donné à la fin de
l'été on n'aurait jamais dû parler de
déconfinement on aurait dû maintenir le
discours de ça reste dangereux
la maladie road la maladie nous guette
parce que en envoyant le message
condé confinés pendant l'été on a comme
envoyer le message qu'on pouvait
relâcher la garde alors qu'il fallait
pas relâcher la garde d'une certaine
façon parce que justement la baladier a
repris du poil de la bête alors on est
en train d'essayer de rattraper si on
veut le message qu'on a un peu échappé à
la fin de l'été et ça c'est très
difficile parce que les mois qui s'en
viennent sont les plus difficiles de
l'année où ce nom c'est maintenant sur
la scène fédérale sur ce qui s'est
produit sur le fait qu'encore une fois
le gouvernement trudeau minoritaires
survécu à un vote de confiance
madame double commande les parties se
sont positionnés qu'est ce qu'on doit
tirer comme conclusion comme analyse
survécu justin trudeau s'il s'il n'avait
pas survécu s'arrêter de sa propre photo
parce que c'est lui qui s'est placée
dans une situation de subir un vote de
confiance il n'avait pas à le faire donc
comme quoi il n'y avait pas trop peur
d'aller en élections et ça c'est ce
qu'on peut tirer de la semaine que le
gouvernement trudeau n'a pas peur
d'aller en élections donc ça va
probablement pas été toutes les
prochaines négociations avec les partis
d'opposition
mais en même temps c'est venus siphonner
aussi une bonne partie je vous dirais de
la bonne volonté qui restait à la
chambre des communes surtout de la part
du npd qui s'est vu coincer
il avait devant lui deux mauvais choix
soit soit faire survivre justement le
gouvernement trudeau et a donné
l'impression qu'il était dans la poche
du gouvernement ou soit aller en
élections alors qu'il n'était pas prêt
donc la seule chose que le npd a gagné
c'est du temps du temps pour essayer de
ramasser davantage
argent pouvoir se payer des pancartes
électorales lorsque viendront
nécessairement un moment donné les
élections moi je pense pas qu'il va en
avoir avant noël la fenêtre commencent à
se refermer
mais en même temps je veux pas engager
beaucoup d'argent là-dessus parce que je
suis pas certaine et sinon mois selon
moi là ce que j'entends en coulisses
c'est que c'est pour le prochain le
prochain rendez vous c'est probablement
celui du budget au printemps mais on
verra bien évidemment moi je vous je
vais vous confier que quand j'ai
commencé ma semaine le lundi matin je
m'attendais pas à tout ce psychodrame
qu'on devine donc je ne peux pas tout le
temps lire dans les feuilles de thé non
mais alex et valen madeleine dié justin
trudeau avait pas peur d'aller en
élection c'est tout à fait vrai mais
peut-être qu'il n'avait pas peur de se
faire renverser son gouvernement parce
qu'il le fait la lecture qu'on a fait
c'est à dire que le npd n'était pas en
mesure de voter avec les conservateurs
pour renverser le gouvernement puis
plonger le pays en élections
dpd manque d'argent ça va être difficile
de trouver des candidats
il n'y a pas de vent npd actuellement au
payer donc probablement justin trudeau
en faisant de ce vote sur la création
d'un comité d'ailleurs ça on comprend
pas trop pourquoi il en a fait un vote
de confiance doit mais il savait que
lille plongerait probablement pas en
élections et ça lui permet de gouverner
un peu comme un parti majoritaire c'est
ça exactement res qui sait que le npd
est que jusqu'à preuve du contraire le
fera pas basculer en élections on a
beaucoup parlé du npd des libéraux les
conservateurs notre ca écoutant monsieur
o'toole qui s'exprime un peu plus tôt
cette semaine
c'est totalement inapproprié pour pour
monsieur trudeau 2-2 de poser à 2-2
d'avoir des menaces telles élections
1 pendant une pandémie et on va
continuer de poser des questions
raisonnable le npd est passé de la zone
orange à la zone rouge
ce passage de la zone orange à la zone
rouge nous permet de regarder passer oui
charity considérable scandale mettant en
cause un premier ministre et son
ministre des finances et des avantages
obtenus pour leurs familles donc pendant
du parti conservateur et de sa position
dans tout ça et au cours des semaines et
mois à venir matelas ni le parti
conservateur ne pas nécessairement
briller dans toute cette histoire là
entre autres parce que il le lui même
reculé en partie en sur la création de
ce comité là qui devait s'appeler un
comité anti-corruption et il a
probablement réalisé qui est allé un peu
trop loin
un peu trop loin parce que renault tools
quand il est arrivé au pouvoir au pas au
pouvoir mais à la tête de son parti
voulait montrer qu'il était différent
d'un gros schirck qu'il n'était pas
seulement un expert partis d'opposition
mais un gouvernement en attente et avec
tout l'épisode qu'on vient de vivre il
donnait plutôt l'impression d'un super
partis d'opposition prêt à critiquer
prêt à démolir le gouvernement mais pas
nécessairement se placer en position
d'un gouvernement en attente et le parti
conservateur ne voulaient pas
d'élections donc plus vain donc
et il a bien écrit dans une dans un
amendement à sa motion
on ne considère pas que la création d'un
comité soit une raison valable d'aller
en élections donc il voulait pas aller
en élection monsieur autour parce que
non plus n'est pas tout à fait prêt il
est pas très bien connu des canadiens ça
fait pas si longtemps qu'il est en poste
comme chef de parti donc et il réalise
lui aussi qu'il faut peut-être mesurer
ses actions au parlement donc ça c'est
pour le parti conservateur
le bloc québécois était peut-être celui
qui était le principal l'observateur
principal de toute cette dynamique là il
y avait un moins grand rôle à jouer
il est
il serait pas nécessairement en mauvaise
posture si la veille d'une élection
vu les sondages mais en même temps sa
position dans un gouvernement
minoritaire est quand même assez
enviable en ce moment s'il les libéraux
ont obtenu une majorité ce serait plus
difficile pour eux de tirer leur épingle
du jeu potentiel on va poursuivre
maintenant puisqu'il temps file avec le
chef de l'assemblée des premières
nations ont péri belgrade qui demande ni
plus ni moins la démission d'un
commissaire de la grc blâme l'eau qui
dans la foulée des actions ou de
l'inaction de la grc dans ces tensions
entre pêcheurs autochtones et non
autochtones en nouvelle écosse juste pas
si on est en mesure de voir les tweets
de monsieur de monsieur belgrade et pour
voir un peu bellegarde et voilà on va
les voir ici
considérant des mois d'instabilité des
multiples problèmes liés à la sécurité
des premières nations je vais écrire au
premier ministre hugo pour lui dire que
le lien de confiance avec la commissaire
à la grc héron plus quand même quand
même et ça s'ajoute dans un contexte où
on le voit les tensions avec les
autochtones sont vives un peu partout au
pays
sébastien whip il y avait un problème de
relation entre les lits nation
autochtone les autochtones et la police
au canada c'est comme ci est ce que je
te problème de formation des policiers
est ce que c'est un problème de
communication entre les communautés où
les leaders de ces communautés et la
police est ce que c'est une culture
d'entreprise entre guillemets dans la
police aussi pour qu'on se pose toutes
ces questions mais y est comme un
mouvement actuellement 2 qui souffle
dans les voiles des nations autochtones
pour revendiquer vous savez on oublie là
mais au début de l'année il y avait des
blocus ferroviaire rappelez vous on a
une situation dans le parc de la
vérendrye aussi ici au québec y aller à
faire de la nouvelle écosse est comme un
mouvement qui pousse les communautés
autochtones pis l'idée c'est de briser
des barrières ou de dénoncer des
situations qui perdure depuis trop
longtemps
est-ce qu'ils ont raison ici demandé la
démission de la commissaire je suis pas
convaincu mais disons qu'il ya ce
mouvement de revendications qu'ils aient
poussé killer les incite à faire ce
genre de sortie mais pour me suis vite
en malaisie en même temps perry
bellegarde comme chef national de
l'assemblée des premières nations n'est
pas celui qu'il est qui est le plus
revendicateurs donc d'aller jusque là
d'aller jusqu'à demander la démission de
madame loki c'est quand même important
comme mouvement est probablement qu'on
voit véritablement que la confiance et
les rompus donc c'est pas banal comme
comme tweet de la part du chef national
des premières nations
très bien on en prend 1,1 t on prend
note aussi que la semaine prochaine il
ya élection partielle
non tu n'as toronto centre un certain
maxime bernier qui va tenter sa chance
dans la circonscription à côté de son
ami paul présenter là donc deux chefs de
partis qui se présentent dans les
élections partielles de ski pas banal
vous n'en parlez sûrement avec patrice
saucourt de la semaine prochaine merci
bien bon week end porter vos livres
week-end au revoir